- [Voiceover] When we last
left off in the riveting saga
of quadratic approximations
of multi variable functions,
we were approximating a two
variable function, f of xy,
and we ended up with this
pretty monstrous expression,
and because it's written its
full abstract form, I almost
feel like it looks more
monstrous than it needs to,
so I'm going to go ahead
and go through a specific
example here, and just to
remind you of kind of what
all these terms are, how
there's actually kind of a
pattern to what's going
on, this here represents,
you can think of it as the
constant term, where you know
this is just going to evaluate
to some kind of number.
These two terms are what you
might call the linear term,
linear, because if you
actually look, the only places
where the variable x
and y comes up is here,
where it's just being
multiplied by a constant,
and here, where it's just
being multiplied by a constant,
so it's just variables
times constant in there.
And then all of this stuff
at the end, which is kind of
the whole essence of a
quadratic approximation,
where you start to have things
like you get an x squared,
and you get x gets to be multiplied by y,
all of this stuff is the
quadratic term, and though
it seems like a lot now,
you'll see in the context
of an actual example, it's
not necessarily as bad
as it seems.
So let's say we're looking
at the function f of xy
and let's say it's going to be
e to the x divided by two,
multiplied by sin of y.
This is our multi variable function.
And let's say we want to
approximate this near some
kind of point, and I'm going
to choose a point that's
something that we can
actually evaluate these at,
so like x, it would be
convenient if that was zero,
and then y, I'll go with
pi halves, because that's
something where I'll
know how to evaluate sin,
and where I'll know how to
evaluate its derivatives,
things like that.
So we're trying to
approximate this function near
this point.
Now first things first.
We're just going to need
to get all of the different
partial derivatives and
second partial derivatives.
We know we're going to need
them, so let's just kind
of start working it through,
and figuring out what
all of them are.
Let's start with the partial
derivative with respect to x.
So this is also a function of xy,
and we look up at the original function,
the only place where x shows
up is in this e to the x
over two, the derivative
of that is one half,
we bring down that one half,
times e to the x over two,
and this is being multiplied
by something that looks
like a constant, as far as x is concerned,
sin of y.
Now when we do the partial
derivative with respect to y,
what we get,
this first part just looks
like a constant, so we kind
of keep that constant there,
as far as y is concerned,
and the derivative of sin is cosin.
Cosin of y.
And then now we
let's start taking second
partial derivatives,
so I'll start by doing the one where
we take the partial derivative
with respect to x twice.
Now here I'll actually do
this in a different color.
Let's do yellow.
Just to make clear which
ones are the second
partial derivatives.
So partial with respect to x twice,
also, function of xy,
like all of these guys.
So let's look up at the
original partial derivative with
respect to x, and we're
now going to take its
derivative, again with respect to x.
This is the only place where x shows up,
that one half kind of comes down again,
so now it's going to be one fourth times
e to the x over two,
and we just keep that sin of y,
because it looks like
we're just multiplying
by a constant, sin of y.
Next we'll do the mixed partial
derivative, where you do
first with respect to x,
then with respect to y,
or you could do it the other
way, because with almost
all functions, it kind
of doesn't matter which
order you take the two.
So I'll go ahead and
just look at the one that
was with respect to x,
and now let's think of its
derivative with respect to y.
This whole one half e to the x halves
looks like a constant,
derivative of sin of y
is cosin y.
So we take that constant,
the one half e to the
x halves,
and then we multiply it by
the derivative of sin of y,
which is cosin of y.
And then finally we take
the second derivative,
second partial derivative
with respect to y, twice in a row.
So f with respect to y,
twice in a row.
And for this one, let's
take a look at the partial
derivative with respect to y.
This part is the only
part where y shows up,
derivative of cosin is negative sin,
and then e to the x halves just
still looks like a constant,
so we'll bring that negative out front,
that constant e to the x halves,
and it was negative sin,
so that negative went out front,
sin of y.
So that's all of the partial
differential information
that we're going to need.
And now we know we're
going to need to evaluate
all of these guys, all of
these partial derivatives
at the specific point,
because if we go up and
look at the original
function that we have,
we're going to need to
evaluate f at this point,
both of the partial
derivatives at this point,
the second partial derivatives.
Oh, I'm realizing, actually,
that I made a little
bit of a mistake here.
This should be a one half
out in front of each of these guys.
That should be plus
one half of this second
partial derivative, and
partial derivative.
The mixed partial
derivative it's still one,
but these guys should have a one half.
That was a mistake on my part.
In any case, though, we're
going to need to evaluate
all of these guys, so if we go back down,
let's just start plugging
in the point zero and
pi halves to each one of these.
So the function itself,
when we plug in zero,
e to the zero is one,
and sin of pi halves,
sin of pi halves is also one,
so this entire thing just comes to one.
If we do this for the next one, again
e to the zero is going to be one,
sin of y is also going to be one,
but now we have that
one half sitting there,
so that'll end up as one half.
If we look at the partial
derivative with respect
to y, cosin of pi halves is zero,
so this entire thing is going to be zero.
Moving right along, let's
take a look at this second
partial derivative with respect to x.
Again, e to the zero will be one,
and sin of pi halves will be one,
so this ends up just
being that one fourth,
the mixed partial derivative here,
if we have one half by the
pattern's starting to continue,
you've got the one, this
one's actually zero,
so cosin of pi halves is zero,
so the whole thing will be zero.
And then the last one it'll be negative
one times that one again,
for sin of pi halves is one,
so all of that just comes
out to be negative one.
So this, I mean I kind of
chose a convenient example,
where all the derivatives
look very similar to the
thing itself, which is
actually pretty common,
so we get to leverage
a lot of the work that
we did earlier.
So now we have these
six different constants,
can't keep them all on the
screen at the same time.
But we've got these six
different constants,
so now we just plug each
one of them in to the
quadratic approximation.
So if we make our quadratic
approximation of our function,
the first term is that constant term,
so we take a look up and
we say where does f of xy
go at this point, and it'll just be one.
We're going to have to do
a lot of scrolling back
and forth here.
There's a lot of text to deal with.
The next thing is going to be something
times x minus zero, the
kind of x coordinate
of our specified point,
and that something is
the first derivative with
respect to x, so that's
going to be one half.
So come back down here.
That one half.
And then similarly, we're
going to have something
multiplied by y minus the y coordinate
of the point about which
we are approximating,
and for that we take a look
at the partial derivative
with respect to y, which was just zero,
so that's pretty convenient.
That's just going to end up being zero.
And then for the second
partial derivative terms,
maybe I'll actually be able to keep it on
the same screen here.
We're going to have
something multiplied by x
minus its coordinate squared,
and that something is whatever
the partial derivative
with respect to x twice
is, which is one fourth,
so we go ahead and plug in one fourth,
and then for the mixed partial derivative,
I'll put it down here,
it'll be something multiplied
by x, minus its constant,
and then y minus
that pi halves,
and that something is the
mixed partial derivative,
which in this case is zero.
Oh and I'm realizing I made
the same mistake again.
It's not one fourth, it's one half.
For the same reason that I
made a mistake up here earlier,
where it's actually one
half multiplied by this
second partial derivative,
and one half by the second
partial derivative there, I
guess I keep forgetting that.
Good lesson, I suppose, that
that's an easy thing to forget,
if you find yourself
computing one of these,
where I'll put it in here,
multiply that guy by one half.
It's similar to a Taylor
expansion in single variable
calculus, where you kind
of have to remember what's
what that squared term
would be, has a one half
associated with it.
So for that same reason,
now we're going to have,
and this time I won't forget it,
will be one half multiplied by something,
multiplied by the y minus pi halves,
minus that y coordinate of
the point we're approximating
there, and this time that something
is negative one.
So we can kind of plug
in here negative one.
And now this is something
we can simplify quite a bit,
because that one stays there,
one half of x minus zero,
that's just x halves,
this whole part cancels out to zero,
so there's nothing there.
Over here we have half
times a fourth, one eighth
times x squared, so that's
x squared divided by eight.
This mixed partial
derivative term is zero,
so that's pretty nice.
And then this last term here is just
negative one half,
so let's see, I'll write
it down as negative
one half by y minus pi halves squared,
by y minus pi halves squared.
So that is the quadratic approximation,
and you can see this actually feels like a
quadratic function.
We've got up to x squared,
and up to y squared,
and there's a sense in which this is a
simpler function.
I mean, it looks like it's
got more terms than the
original one, which was e
to the x halved sin of y,
but if it's a computer
that needs to compute these
things, for example, it's
much easier to deal with
polynomials, that's a faster thing to do.
Also for theoretical
purposes, it can be nice to
deal with just a quadratic
polynomial to make
conclusions about things.
We'll see that in the context
of something called the
second partial derivative test.
But just to get a feel for
what this means, let's pull
up the graph of the relevant functions.
So this here is the graph
of the original function,
e to the x halves times sin of y,
and the point that
we're approximating near
was where x equals zero,
so let's see how we get oriented.
X is equal to zero, and then
y is equal to pi halves.
So this is the point
we're approximating near.
And the quadratic approximation,
when you plug everything
in, has a graph that looks
like this white surface here.
So if I get rid of that
original graph, this is how
we're approximating the
function near that point.
And that does a pretty good job, right?
Because even as you step
pretty far away from that
point, it's pretty closely
hugging the original surface.
If you go very far away,
it certainly doesn't get
the oscillating nature
of that sin component,
and the exponential
component grows faster than
the quadratic one, but nearby,
nearby this actually
gives a very good feel for
the shape of the graph.
And again, later on we'll
see how this is a pretty
useful theoretical tool for
drawing conclusions about
qualitative features of
the shape of the graph,
the fact that this looks
kind of like a saddle,
is going to end up being kind of important
in certain contexts.
But before we get to any
of that, in the next couple
videos I'm going to talk about a simpler,
or rather a more generalizable form,
of writing down this
quadratic approximation
using vector notation.
Because right now we're just limited to
two variables, and you can
imagine how monstrous this
might look if you were
dealing even just with a
three variable function,
where think of all the
different possible second
partial derivatives of a
three variable function,
or a four variable function.
It would quickly get out
of hand, but there is kind
of a nice general way
to write all of these.
So with that, I will see you next video.